hello fellow humans this is andrew
tarvin ceo of humor that works and today
we've got a case of the mondays
in this video we're going to talk about
the dangers of humor because you all
know that it's not always puppy dogs and
milkshakes when it comes to using humor
especially in the workplace
i'm sure we've all been there when that
one bro in sales decides he wants to
lighten the mood with a joke and it's
just straight up racist
so a white guy a black guy and an asian
guy walking into a synagogue you know
i'm gonna stop you right there jerry
at a high level humor can be harmful in
one of three ways
first it can distract people from what's
going on around them or keep them from
focusing on the right things humor when
used well actually helps you accomplish
the work at hand but used poorly it
prevents work from getting done
that's something that happens when
office pranks go wrong like in 2013 when
co-workers at intel secretly taped a
kick me sign to the back of one of their
employees backs as a prank
because when you're looking for a good
prank what better place to start than on
the middle school playground next up is
telling your coworker that they've been
diagnosed sadly
with cooties
i get it we all have co-workers we'd
love to give a flying kick in the pants
too and while you can do that
figuratively you can't do that literally
because that's distracting and
technically a crime in fact in the case
of intel two employees were convicted of
misdemeanor battery and fired by the
company
april fool's pranks can be such a
distraction that it's led to some
companies like microsoft banning them in
the office leading to the hrest of hr
sentences
data tells us these stunts have limited
positive impact and can actually result
in unwanted news cycles that's how
dangerous inappropriate humor is
the cliche goes from no such thing as
bad press to unwanted news cycles which
to me sounds a bit like a craigslist ad
for sale unwanted news cycle complete
with unintended consequences pranks gone
wrong and whoops i probably shouldn't
have tweeted that
to avoid using humor that distracts be
specific about what you're trying to
achieve
but distraction isn't the only danger of
humor humor can also divide people
positive inclusive humor brings people
together but insular humor creates in
and out groups and accentuates power
differences consider the case of gerald
ratner who in 1991 was the ceo of the
uk's biggest jewelry chain
in a speech at a conference ratner made
jokes about his own products and his
customers
uh we sell gifts as well as jewelry
things like a teapot for two quid um or
we've got this imitation book that you
lay on your coffee table the pages don't
actually open uh but
they're beautiful curled up corners with
imitation antique dust i know it's you
might say it's not in the
best possible taste
but we sold a quarter of a million of
them last year
people say to me how can you sell this
for such a low price
i say because it's total crap
[Applause]
it's no point beating around the bush
anyway
you can tell he was really enjoying it i
mean you can see it on his face look at
him he's thinking man i am totally
nailing this right now
in fact the audience in the room was
eating it up but this is a case of
having two audiences the group sitting
in that room other business owners
versus his actual customers who did not
enjoy the jokes the next morning this
speech made national headlines like
jewelry ceo calls his own products crap
the sunday times dubbed him gerald
kratner instead of ratner which is
showcasing just how funny newspaper
editors can be
as the hustle shared within a few days
of the speech ratner's group shares
dropped by 500 million pounds some say
funny is money but that's an expensive
joke and he only spoke for 25 minutes
that's 20 million pounds per minute
that's the suez canal of speaking gaffes
the problem wasn't that ratner used
humor in his speech that's typically a
good thing to do if the humor is
connected to the topic and positive
inclusive
but the problem was that it was divisive
humor it created two groups the haves
and the have-nots the ins and the outs a
similar divide can happen with
constantly using inside jokes without
explaining them to other people for
those not in on the joke they may feel
like they're not one of the team
inside jokes say we're cool with each
other but uh not with you
it's like michael scott from the office
i love inside jokes
love to be a part of one someday
it's funny but also sad it's facet
to prevent your humor from dividing make
sure it's inclusive and that you bring
other people along
and the final danger of humor is that it
can disparage others and i know
disparage is just a fancy way of saying
insult but insult doesn't start with d
like distract and divide
at its best humor is a positive force
for good at its worst it's a tool that
can suppress ideas and destroy
self-esteem in 2011 three employees at
the iowa civil rights commission were
fired after their boss found gossipy
emails attacking co-workers and
assigning them derogatory nicknames the
employees claim they were just joking
but the nicknames included monster teen
wolf and homeless mcgee
sure it's sometimes hard to tell if a
person in the office is homeless or just
works in the creative department but
these aren't positive nicknames they're
just insults
positive nicknames can bring people
together like when my bowling coach gave
me the nickname silk
and i realized there's a lot to unpack
in that one statement yes i was on a
varsity bowling team my senior year i
did have a coach and you would call me
stoke because my role was so smooth
silk still got it
a lot of the cases where employees are
fired because of jokes are because they
were offensive or disparaging to others
like the uber board director who is
dismissed after this sexist joke at an
all hands meeting ariana huffington was
speaking about the board saying there's
a lot of data that shows when there's a
woman on the board it's much more likely
that there will be a second woman on the
board
david piped in to say actually what it
shows is that it's much more likely to
be more talking
get it
because of that
hilarious stereotype that women talk a
lot
oh i don't know maybe maybe though he
meant it as a positive maybe he meant
that there's more likely to be talking
about how well the company is doing
considering companies with women
directors on their board perform better
than those without women
to avoid humor that disparages others
focus on positive affiliative humor
rather than what you might see in a
comedy club or use with your closest
friends
now just because there are dangers to
using humor at work it doesn't mean that
we should avoid it completely
that'd be like saying we should never
take the stairs because you could fall
down them that's ridiculous we know we
just have to be careful we just have to
take it one step at a time
there's plenty of research that shows
the benefits to using humor in the
workplace
but in order to get these benefits you
can't just rely on the humor you use
with your friends or what you see on tv
part of the skill of humor is knowing
what's appropriate and when
if you want to learn how to effectively
use humor in the workplace you can find
out more at www.humorthatworks.com
and if you like this video be sure to
like and subscribe to hear more humor
tips
until next time i've been andrew tarvin
you've been whoever you are